the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
[Music]
and welcome everyone to round five of
the 2022 spring chess classic i am
grandmaster alejandro ramirez here to
bring you the coverage of the action
with my good friend grandmaster
christian carrillo alejandro always a
pleasure to be commentating on these
amazing games from this amazing studio
here at the st louis chess club good to
be here let's take a look at what we
have for you it's two round robins very
strong players here not quite u.s
championship not quite the same field
cup but entertaining games nonetheless
and a star-studded field let's see where
they are sitting at right now after four
rounds of chess let's start with group a
and we have two leaders it's ray robson
that is an alum from webster university
sharing first place with a current
webster university chess player aram
hakobian they've both been scintillating
three out of four for both players and
they're followed closely by geoffrey
ilya nishnik and hans demon tied in
sixth position we have sam savion and
darius zverge who seems to be on the
comeback tied for seventh position we
have mikhail antipov and alex lenderman
unfortunately both of these players
don't seem to be in the form of their
lives neither is camille dragoon in 10th
position he lost yesterday as well he
only scored half a point out of five
possible games so far and how about the
b group alejandro in the beaker we have
an absolute clear leader it's chris
repko with four out of four dominating
the field but despite that he is still
being followed closely by christopher
you still a point away from him both of
these players won yesterday another
person that won yesterday is our clear
third place abi manu mishra moving to
plus one after a nice victory yesterday
there he's currently in clear third
place meanwhile with fifty percent we
have el shawn murray adiabatic and titus
ramavichis and we do have a big tie for
the sixth place with one and a half
points out of four we have robert
hungaski the rating favorite of this
event jj alimorandi sam kanin and arman
mikaelian and unfortunately for harshid
raja his soul in 10th place with only
half a point so far the terminal format
for you as we see the players already
there in action it is a 2 10 player
round robin the time control is simple
90 minutes for 40 moves with an extra 30
second increment from move one and of
course once you reach mu 40 like in most
classical tournaments nowadays you get
an extra 30 minutes of thinking time
also the players may not mutually agree
to a draw in less than 40 moves they can
find that elusive repetition they can
find the perpetual to make that draw but
they cannot mutually agree to a draw and
this is going to ensure that we have a
very combative event here at the same
chess club the schedule one round a day
we start every day at 1pm central of
course not
in the last day that's the only
exception because we want to accommodate
playoffs first place will be determined
by an over the board shootout so if
necessary don't miss those though at the
moment we do have two clear leaders in
both sections and coverage as usual
starts two and a half hours in so 3 30
on most days on thursday march 10th will
be starting at 1 30 p.m central also
don't forget to join uh the conversation
you can write us specifically on twitter
that's where we are most active at
spring chess classic ask us your
questions and we will answer them also
it's very important this show is
broadcast both on youtube and twitch and
on twitch if you donate uh well every 75
dollars is going to help a scholastic
student
go from a semester in at the same level
absolutely this is the bridge that is
chat provides to the community taking
them from scholastic players all the way
to the super elite this is one of the
many stepping stones and for scholastic
players that semester those 75 will
sponsor a kit for a full semester so if
you can donate even if it's a few
dollars here a couple of players can get
together highly appreciate it we really
highly appreciate it we're not doing it
for ourselves doing it for the community
so help us out with that one and
meanwhile let's take a look at what we
have in store for you today pairings of
group a alex slenderman is playing
against sam savion this is already a
classic matchup in u.s championships
meanwhile camille dragoon has been a
little luckless in this tournament is
finding his form against hans niemann
dario spears is playing in a battle of
collegiate chess against haram hakobian
and mikhail antipov is playing against
ray robson but certainly the game of the
day has to be this one two of the
highest rated players in the tournament
jeffrey schong against ilya nishnik
former super prodigies now well
established grandmasters both of them
with two and a half points trailing the
leaders by only half a point so they do
feel a little bit of pressure to
accumulate points
but
not fully
panic mode quite yet if they want to win
the tournament as we see we do see
jeffrey who has been a little bit of
form i would say in this tournament
trying his best we'll get back into this
game as soon as we are done with the b
perrys and speaking of them we have them
in front of us the b parries are also
more bodies playing as christopher you
jj alimorandi has actually already
finished that game against harshid raja
that finished in a draw uh abdominal
mushroom is currently playing as rupert
hingoski titustromovicious has also
drawn his game against sam ghanin so
we'll just go very quickly over it and
the
battle of the day has to be clear he is
the sharpest man up there definitely the
best dressed and over the board his
tactics have been the best in group b
four out of four is currently the score
of chris rafka he's trying to add to
that score by playing against another
collegiate player armand mikhailian who
represents university of texas at rio
grande valley they are currently the
national champions but will not be
defending their championship in the
final four this year as they were unable
to qualify
alejandro you were mentioning a very
important game of today's round and that
is in group a the big clash between
jeffrey shong and ilya nishnik and let's
remember what the trends look like for
these two players well yesterday jeffrey
sean also with the white pieces just
like today he lost against aram hakobian
well he didn't play a good game
yesterday and he's not really playing a
very good game today either ilya nizhnik
on the other hand he won a brilliant
game against the struggling camille
dragoon yesterday so let's see what is
happening right now in this big clash
well after losing yesterday against aram
hacobian jeffrey decided to go for it to
go all in he started with a move e4 and
the players soon entered into a very
very sharp and theoretical night or
defense knight to f6 knight to c3 a6
bishop to e3 e5 knight to b3 of course
we see nowadays uh white play absolutely
every single move possible on the board
in this position knight to b3 knight to
e rook to g1 bishop to g5 f3 f4 anything
you can think of bishop to d2 also but
of course the main line remains bishop
to e3 e5 knight to b3
bishop to e6 f3 and of course white is
uh preparing for an avalanche of a pawn
storm on the king side potentially with
a move g4 g5 uh displays this knight
from f6 and black has this interesting
alternative of trying to stop that early
on
with the move h5 and this is exactly
what he does white continues with his
plan of finishing his development on the
queen side getting the king on c1
castling long and now we have this
position king to b1 this is by the way
still everything that we've seen so far
is syrian has been played before rook to
c8 g3 quite an interesting approach of
course
white needs to find a way to break
through on this side and the best way to
do that would be to take advantage of
the hook on h5 with a potential h3 and
then g4 the problem with h3 is that
black can immediately stop that with the
move h4 so what white has to do before
he plays this move h3 is to play the
move g3 and this is exactly what we see
on the board bishop to e7 and he decides
to go for h4 a different approach
potentially solidifying this pawn on h5
and targeting it later on in the game b5
knight to d5 knight takes d5 e takes d5
bishop to f5 immediately targeting the
pawn on c2 i would love as white to not
have to play this move bishop to d3 but
rather to prepare this move g4 and
target the bishop f5 unfortunately i
cannot play bishop e2 because the pawn
on c2 is hanging the bishop on f5
despite the fact that it doesn't have
that many squares is a very very uh
potent attacking piece and that's why
jeffrey decides to exchange that with
bishop to d3 and we see at this position
he takes g takes queen to c4 offering
the queen trade well white doesn't want
a queen trade white wants to blast
through with a move f5 try to open up
the position in front of the black king
and checkmate that is the only viable
plan at this point for white because the
pawn structure is definitely favorable
for black so white has to find the
dynamic in the position bishop takes h4
rook to f1 rook to e8 f5 as i was
mentioning bishop to f6 rook to f4
attacking the queen
and this is a very beautiful transition
from ilya nishnik of course you can go
queen to c7 and stay passive like this
but it feels like right now white is
definitely on the offensive i can
definitely put this rook on g1
potentially solidify my position on the
queen side first with the move c3 and
then bring all my pieces towards the
attack well instead of that black
spotted this very nice combination with
queen takes c2 simplifying the position
and transitioning into a much better end
game because after queen takes two rook
takes e2 you have to take rook takes e3
and now we see
you did get an exchange as white but i
do have two very very um dangerous pawns
on the king side ready to march down the
board ready to promote and unfortunately
for uh jeffrey it doesn't seem like his
position is getting any better this is
going to be a very very difficult
defense also i'm looking at the clocks
right now this is move number 28 you
have a very difficult position as white
12 moves to go and only 14 minutes while
your opponent is pretty much playing at
double your speed 33 minutes and 55
seconds for ilya nishnik we know he's a
very fast player but right now the
pressure is definitely on jeffrey and
well he could be losing two games in a
row with the white pieces alejandro what
do you think of that no i would never
have predicted that he is such an
experienced player also somebody that
knows very well how to play these
particular tournaments having won the
spring chess classic a group three in
three different occasions i think he's
the only person i've ever done that uh
yeah for sure he's the only person i've
ever done that we haven't even had that
many
but
uh he looks like i mean it looks pretty
hopeless it's not just
the fact that his position is bad but
you look at it from a practical point of
view and maybe a computer will tell you
it's really not that bad white can hold
it but
black has a plan you put something on e5
it really doesn't matter what it is you
put a bishop or you put a knight on e5
and then you push your pawns
and
you kind of ask the question from white
what is your idea
what are you going to create us we see
ilia just walking around he has very
he's very well aware of what his plan is
and jeffrey has so many questions to
answer including what do i do with all
of these uh pawns
rolling around down on the board so
speaking of that game that jeff ilia
seemed to be so interested in i have it
up on the board it's another one of
those high rated games in the tournament
it's also a very important game for the
standings as dario sphere currently
sitting on 50
is playing against aram hakobian who is
sitting on plus two having an absolutely
excellent tournament defeating jeffrey
schong yesterday and having one against
um
why is this eluding me he won another
game
i cannot remember either i want to say
it was either lender lenderman i want to
say ilya nishik no no no no
aram who did iran be aram yesterday he
drew against antipov so he won against
jeffrey yeah he beat somebody else but i
cannot remember remember exactly who it
was we'll look it up don't worry about
it but
at this point he is definitely on the
defensive side i think it's the first
time that i see him on the defensive
side in this tournament as he is playing
my student at st louis university dario
scherz and it's clear that he's on the
defensive not only because he has less
space he just has an uh is down upon
this pawn on e5 is simply extra
let me show you more or less how this
happened this came from an open spanish
i'm not going to bog down on the details
of the opening but
this is not considered to be the main
line of the spanish of the open spanish
right now but we did see it uh in a
couple of locations
and i find it
not fully equal
and it was clear that something went
wrong here for black when after the move
knight d6
he decided to just leave the knight on
d4 alone he didn't take on f3 he didn't
do any of the other possible solutions
he has to defend this pawn on the on d4
you can see that white is attacking it
three times actually four times uh but
he doesn't move the knight he just kind
of stays there he could have taken on f3
but perhaps he didn't like the dynamic
possibilities i'm assuming of queen f3
moving the queen somewhere and f4 f5
maybe even gtx f3 and f4 f5 i wasn't
even considering that yeah i don't have
an engine but g takes and maybe this is
also quite dangerous with the king
coming to h1 and rook on g1 you don't
have the light score bishop as black to
pose any problems on that long diagonal
and i do have that very nice centralized
queen on e4 defending everything and to
me the main problem with black's
position here is that you're not only
down the light square bishop i also
think you're down the dark squared
bishop because this guy is just not
participating in the game it's being
blocked by his own pawn so it doesn't
have any influence on the king side you
have to shed a pawn every time you want
to bring it back and it doesn't have any
another diagonal to go through right a4
is always going to lose upon as well so
the bishop is solid but solid is not
good when you're attacking on the king
side this would be a very dangerous
situation for black so he decided to
play in a little bit more of a practical
way shedding this pawn on c5 immediately
in order to
uh bring the bishop back into the game
so we have this simplification you
couldn't enter mezzo at any point with
bishop takes d6 because knight b5
attacks both the queen and the bishop
that regains my pawn
so after
knight takes queen takes we get this
position where black has the spin
a source of counter play it's not
trivial to unpin and it's also not
trivial to see where white is going to
make progress
but he is up a pawn and he does have a
ton of space and it feels that he is a
couple of accurate moves away
from putting realistic winning winning
pressure on black's position
for the moment i think uh he needs to
keep as many pawns on the queen side
alive as he can it'll make his life
easier to convert not to trade the b for
the a if you only have one flank it'll
be a lot easier for black to hold but
the knight on d6 is pretty much a
monster
and it's it's difficult to take the
reason it's difficult to take is that
whenever a pawn lands on d6 either
before or after i take with the rook on
d6
it just
it just jams in black's pieces they just
can't move there's not a lot of
maneuverable room for this works on d7
and d8 and you might be wondering well
what am i going to do with all this
maneuvering room i still only have and
usually the
what you do is that you combine threats
with the pawn promoting and advancing
which stuck
creates this uh
rooks being stuck and swinging over this
rook through the king side with d3 or d4
and then g3 or g4 and start creating
immediate tactical threats against the
king that are not always so easy to
answer
so
uh certainly a strong advantage for
dario she's not doing great on the clock
i think he has 16 minutes and 40 seconds
for 13 moves but it's also not so bad
considering his other situations in the
games and it looks like an easy position
to play right the material is quite
limited black doesn't really have any
ways in which you can create any sort of
attack against the white king the white
is the white king is extremely safe you
don't have any structural weaknesses
either and you know that whenever you're
going to see bishop takes d6 because at
some point it does feel like black will
have to take on d6 and that's when i'm
going to take back with the pawn and i'm
just going to have that thorn in your
position on d6 as white which probably
will give me at least from a practical
perspective a winning position yeah it
might be one of those positions again we
we thought i talked about a little bit
with the jeffrey game you might turn on
an engine and the engine might think you
know this is not that bad you can
actually hold it but it's tough to do so
over the game you don't know the
evaluation of the position and it looks
super super scary uh in many positions
you're just kind of struggling to
survive
no and uh it definitely uh looks like a
dire use might be taking this one and
might be taking
uh aram i think is one of the leaders
yeah he's currently on three out of four
with ray
uh ray's the other uh only player with
three out of four so let's jump to his
game real quick that way we can uh go
around the horn a little bit
um
let me see what's going on so this was a
joke of piano if we go from uh the
beginning and we i see on people play
these joko piano positions quite often
it's kind of it's kind of one of those
guys
that plays the juco piano with black
white in every single game yeah right
nobody's forcing his opponents to go e4
but it somehow feels like every single
game of antipop is an italian yeah yeah
now he really enjoys playing these
positions as white he believes he has
at least a practical advantage because
he has analyzed these positions quite a
lot so
he feels comfortable and nevertheless
unfortunately for him in this event it
doesn't seem like he's getting
the advantages that he usually gets in
the joker piano he won a lot of very
important games in this one against high
caliber players especially some are
russians alekseyenko he beat him once in
this
opening but in this particular event
also against your student darius
virginia doesn't seem to be getting a
huge advantage out of the opening and he
actually lost that game right now once
again he's on the defensive side he's a
pawn down
of course you have probably enough
compensation for equality nevertheless
not more than that and that definitely
doesn't seem to be um something he
enjoys very much yeah let's analyze a
little bit you can see the white
structure is clearly superior to blacks
it's basically one pawn island
uh and black has these two weaknesses on
c7 and a6 but that being said their
weaknesses and it's hard to pick them up
fully
uh it's one of those scenarios in which
you can imagine worst case for black you
shed one pawn and go into an easily
drawn end game but
actually winning this pawn
presents more practical problems than
one would think right it does it does
because white is in some ways
overexposed he's pushed all of these
pawns all the way here that means the
knights anchor squares are very far away
from the king
so if you go something like knight c6 i
can just sidestep it right
yeah if you take back on c6 probably i
will be able to take back with the rook
and it doesn't seem like you're gonna be
able to defend everything even though
you have this check now i have this
double attack so you still think i still
think you lose a pawn and the queen on
a4 is very importantly defensive yeah
and defensive one running four so you
don't have any any trickeries against
this
but um if i just sidestep it there are
so many scenarios in which i wonder
that's a problem yeah the knight on f4
is just better than mine on c6 this is
optically very nice but optics don't win
chess games good moves to win chess
games and a knight c6 might not actually
be in the right direction no i don't
like this knight c6 i want to keep the
knight on d4 so that whenever you try uh
to shift that knight towards the center
vr g6 as you were mentioning i want to
jump to f5 yeah it feels like there's
this kind of uh
dance dance yeah
in english sometimes we call it mind
squares right where like
if one side moves this way you take
advantage of it and you're seeing that
if this knight on e7 ever moves
especially to g6 this knight on f5 is
actually doing something because this
pressure on g7 is annoying and you're
controlling a lot of good squares like
e3 and g3 that you never know when you
might need
so
what is white's move here i'm struggling
to find it right let's make some uh
let's create some basic attacks why
don't we just simply go
[Music]
in fact you know what let's calculate
the most
critical line queen d7
all right queen d7 is certainly
appealing uh it attacks the knight
attacks the pawn you could move this
knight from e-7 but as we mentioned this
is uh at the very least an improved
version of what we've been talking about
so critical would probably be to take on
d4 take on d4 i take on e7
yeah i'm going to lose this pawn the
question is can i do something
in the meantime something like rook ba
the promise you take with the queen i
take with the queen and then i think i
have the perpetual right after you
invade via the second rank i have queen
c8 queen f5 actually not only a
perpetual i'm winning that yeah on the
problem for black is that actually when
the pawn on c7 disappears this rook can
come down to the last rank and deliver a
checkmate and of course you don't want
to play g6 because queen takes f7 is
checked that looks like a hopeless end
game
so queen design might be critical in
this position
uh and after queen takes d4 queen takes
e7 yeah maybe this is just too annoying
of course black isn't no real danger in
this position i can just probably pass
the move even like start pushing this
pawn
and it's hard for white to really
comfortably create threats with this
king on being on g1 but
i also don't think what's in any real
danger
it doesn't seem like it it seems like
the position is extremely close to just
liquidating into a very equal end game i
have to agree let's finish up group a
with what we haven't seen so far
uh there's a bit of a mess i don't think
i can evaluate it as fast as i want it
to
this is camille dragoon with the white
pieces playing against hans niemann
camille who is a player that right now
he's been struggling quite a lot he's
been struggling for a few years i mean
he was
a very solid 26
30 26 40 player represented the polish
team in several key competitions
including the olympiad
but has been struggling uh in his form
in the last few years dropping out of
the 26 2600 club
and during hours christian of the lowly
don't 2500s me
but uh actually this move g4 i like this
move i think it's a very important move
you need to do something uh to disrupt
the pawn structure that black is trying
to set up with the pawn potentially on
f4 and this kind of becomes critical
right what if i do play f4 anyway and
the trick i guess i go knight d3 yes and
the idea is that if you go rogue b7 i
take on f4 i think you can take this
right so rook here now let's say
i'm not sure which one i think i want to
start with no i cannot start with king
g3 because you take on f4 with the
bishop and then rook to e3 which wins
the game this is a very important point
and this the king can no longer defend
the rook black wins this one so order of
operations is always important
rook df1 must be played
and
i don't
think there is a trick here it looks
like black is has tied down white
completely on the file and stuff like
that but
you actually need a trick because if you
give me one more move i'll put mine out
on d3 and i'll be fully and i'll just be
okay i'll be winning thank you for the
free pawn and the blockading knight
yeah and if you have to take on f4 well
that's just a losing end game yeah i
think you might as well not take enough
or not play the move f4 right this g4
was well calculated by dragoon and it
doesn't seem like black has the option
of pushing and solidifying that bishop
on e3 with f4 the thing is that if you
don't play the move f4 you probably have
to take yeah but i'm starting to warm up
to white's position because
the knight comes back
these this is a passport right i can
push it whenever i want and unlike this
pawn on d4 that's already blockaded
under their key
with the beautiful knight on d3
you have to find out which of your
pieces are going to come back and do it
i mean the bishop it takes forever to
retreat to c7 it doesn't have a good
avenue
i feel
i like white's chances here i'm not sure
it's more than a slight edge
but if you gave me the option of which
uh site to take i would definitely take
one right how are we doing on the clock
because i know camille has huge problems
with his time management on this event i
see he has eight minutes four moves
remaining 12 moves
it's not it's not amazing but it's also
not terrible i think for an end game of
this it's a simplified position
absolutely yeah you're not going to get
tricked with a bishop on e3 right it
feels like you should be able to handle
the complications still plenty to play
for for both sides
uh with perfect play i assume it's some
sort of draw uh let me cheat a little
bit i'll peek at the engine valve and
yeah
everything that we said the engine is
saying you guys are actually not so bad
at chess
white is slightly better giving a small
point for edge but visually this is
very understandable
for us
well alejandro let's actually jump to
that game a very important game between
lenderman and uh samsung yeah we haven't
looked at it yet no and this one is
going sam's way with the black pieces
leonardo definitely not finding his form
in this event so this is by the way the
second rough tournament for london
he had a very bad showing in charlotte
not not so long ago where he lost a lot
of rating he seems to be struggling at
least in the past year so let's see what
happened uh in this game e4 e5 knight to
f3 knight to c6 and once again we see a
djoko piano on the board just like in
the game between
antipov and ray robson and now we see
this bishop to c5 knight f6 d3 d6 by the
way this joker piano has been played at
the top level for so many i'm okay with
the bandit i'm okay if the st louis
chess club bans the joker piano for a
year no berlin no joko pianos none of
these allowed in our tournaments you can
play whatever else you want you play
fisher random to start a game if you
feel like it but man i've seen so many
joko pianos in the last
i if i said the last year oh that would
be crazy the last week everybody plays
it the last week i can count how many
important joko pianos were played and
you know why previously the joco piano
was considered to be a very easy opening
to play for both sides and usually was
leading to a very drawish positions
now it's an extremely sharp line
actually and both sides can find
different ideas on a whim we see
different ideas from day to day somebody
plays something this day somebody is
going to improve on that specific
variation the next day and this is
exactly what's happening we see uh this
line with a6 by the way black and play
with a5 black and play with the pawn
still on a7 and bishop b6 ideas black
has a lot of setups that he can try and
after a6 a4 bishop to a7 rook 21 we see
this move knight to g4 without the
castle so black decided to delay the
castle and try this attempt with knight
to g4 which forces white's hand of
course after rook to e2 i'm going to
threaten to play h3 and that's just
going to win me a tempo but let's see
what happened queen to f6
now if you go h3 first of all knight to
h6 is a move but i have a feeling also
h5 is a possible in this position follow
you cannot take on g4 because you're
simply going to get checkmated this is
completely busted for a black i'm going
to go g3 if you try to go knight to g5
continue with g3 and
coupled with the action of the bishop
this very a nasty pin on the a7 g1
diagonal this pawn on g3 ready to
support the checkmating patterns queen
to h6 coming for black doubling up on
the h file and invading for the
checkmate this is just game over you
cannot do that
so
after queen to f6 we see this move
knight bd2 a much more tame approach of
course white is trying to go knight to
f1 knight to g3 reinforce the defensive
setup
around the king potentially exchange
some pieces and i tried to catch black
off guard because of course black played
this move knight to g4 it seems like
he's not going in the right direction
but
what black does at this point is g5
doubling down on this attack on the king
side no castle i'm not even dreaming
about castling on the king side i
actually want to dream i i want to
castle on the queen side so let's see
what happened d4 rook to g8 setting up
the pressure on the g file before knight
to d8 and i do like this maneuver quite
a lot because
knight to d8 supports this idea of
bishop to e6 and after that i'm going to
put the knight on e6 i really want to
get my knight to f4 if i manage to get
the knight to f4 then my position as
black is going to be dominant so let's
see what happened knight to f1 knight to
e6 knight to e3 knight to f4
rook to d2 huge mistake it seems like at
this point white had this golden
opportunity of trying to exchange the
knight and uh take full control of the
position with the move knight to d5 if
you take on d5 well that's a big problem
because right now i'm going to take with
the e pawn and your king is going to be
exposed
terribly exposed in this position with
the e file opening up you have to
sidestep with the move king of f8 but
right now the harmony in your uh in your
camp as a black is not amazing and it
feels like white is taking over after
something along the lines of h3 now if
you go backwards i'm just simply going
to take on e5 grab a pawn and probably
have a winning position
so instead of that after knight to f4
white played this move rook to d2 very
natural move of course you're taking the
rook out of uh the attack of the knight
on f4 but unfortunately after knight
takes e3 f takes e3 this inter mezzo
move i'm not going to uh backtrack with
my knight go back to g6 i'm actually
going to continue pushing for an
immediate attack with this move g4 and
now we have knight to g5 knight h3 check
this is i think the move that he missed
why that is landerman which forces the
opening of the g file and uh this
constant pressure with this pawn this
torn in white position on h3 and right
now we have this position after a few
more moves it seems like white is trying
some sort of an attack on this side but
it's not going anywhere because the
bishop on a7 is just fully controlling
the dark squares you can never play this
move c4 uh to continue your pawn
expansion on the queen side because
that's going to leave the pawn on a d4
very very sensitive so
we have this position king to b8 i
really like what black is doing
he's just getting ready uh for a
potential attack on the king side but
he's not in a hurry
i'm going to improve the position of my
king first i'm going to get this king
all the way to a7 where he's going to be
extremely safe and only after that i'm
going to start preparing for the uh h7
pawn push all the way to h4 and uh
pretty much blast open your position and
win the game and this is the position
you see white is just doing bishop d2
bishop c1 white doesn't have any ways in
which you can improve his position and
we have the king landing on a7 bishop to
d2 queen to h5 i'm probably going to get
uh this queen all the way to g4
supporting this pawn push h5 h4
practically this position is not looking
great from uh for white objectively this
position is not looking great for white
uh this is look
no no it looks like complete trash
this is move 31 yeah the problem is a
bishop we're starting from move 26. look
at white's moves yeah bishop d2 bishop
c1 yeah bishop d2 bishop c1 bishop d2
bishop c1 no he i would be ashamed to
play like this yeah but he's completely
paralyzed right he's just up entirely to
the mercy of his opponent and when he's
gonna when he's gonna take on d4 and go
e5 when he's gonna go h5h4
sam in full control of the position here
against london who's had a really tough
showing he's been able to salvage a
couple of very tough positions including
that one against nizhnik where he was um
he had a queen and a bishop against the
queen and a knight look at him
yeah that move was played with an umph
yeah he knows he knows he's winning this
one yeah he's clearly in control we are
being told that a huge result there for
the standings iliya nizhnik has defeated
jeffrey shawn let's take a look at how
that finished up
um
we left it over after this nice
combination
rookie 2 apparently the computer did not
like very much i don't know why
or king d1 also not a very big fan is
the computer but eventually
what had to happen happened which is
that something established itself on e3
i'm not entirely sure about the move
rook a3 because
can you actually take on a6 here knight
takes d5 seems to come with a lot of
threats i feel knight takes d5 sorry uh
knight xd5 comes with the threat of rook
takes e4 and of 93 check
and i'm not really sure how you're
planning on dealing with with that and
now that i'm noticing that i don't
actually have a
next move i guess jeffrey resigned here
uh a strange
sequence to finish the game honestly
because this looks pretty obvious but uh
it was difficult to suggest anything for
jeffrey at this point it's very
difficult we mentioned to even play this
position out when black has such a clear
plan of pushing his pawns forward and
it's hard to see what white
is going and this is exactly what you
anticipated alejandra you said at the
beginning of this end game the position
objectively was worse but not completely
losing but from a practical perspective
this is just impossible to play as white
you're going to lose in the next 10
moves as he did yeah he didn't even make
it to five and it just
it's more of a concept of how difficult
this position is to play
uh than to how resourceful jeffrey is i
mean he's an incredibly resourceful
player he can kind of clock his way out
of the most difficult positions but this
is a this is an end game that is not new
to to any of us not to ilya not to
jeffrey not to either one of us in the
commentary booth this is a typical night
of position in which once you lose those
two pawns in the gnh file uh you
basically lose there's a lot of end
games like this my my student diary
spirits actually won a very important
game in a pan-american intercollegiate
the exact same way you give up the
exchange bishop on e5 and you roll the
pawns it's a known idea
and i think jeffrey got a little bit too
feisty so much control of the dark
squares given by that bishop in the
center only five right and we are
getting set up with obviously who is
going to be our first guest somebody
that must be very happy from this
position but before we go to him let me
see if i have any big updates in group b
uh it seems just to update everybody uh
elsa maria the body and christopher you
seem to be fighting it out to a draw i
can't imagine this really goes anywhere
else
um
chris rhapko is still down upon
i still think he's probably on the
winning side of being down a pawn
but and in the other game that's
remaining i feel that hungary is getting
made it but we'll analyze that in a
little bit in more detail because we do
have an important winner of today's
round winning again with the black
pieces it's ilya nishnik thank you
alejandro yes we are here with surging
ilia
two in a row how does that feel against
with the black pieces against the top
rated player in the event that's a huge
win yeah that was honestly i did not
really expect myself to to win today's
game plus
i was i honestly did not expect my
opponent to go for such a such a sharp
line in a night of sicily and i honestly
was expecting more uh a more safe option
such as
moves three bishop b5 where the game
would be pretty much even but but he
decided to go for for a really sharp
opening line and uh it was anyone's game
and i'm i'm pretty happy how you know
about the way i played it it's i
honestly don't really know
where he went wrong did you feel um or
uh let's say smells any sort of weakness
uh coming from yesterday's game for
jeffrey because he lost also with the
white business oh i see
yeah um
it seems like yeah
i wouldn't say that i felt something but
i i've already um prepared to to play
in a more of an aggressive style for
this event so that's why i chose
accessory and defense uh unlike uh
unlike my normal uh opening repertoire
which is on a safer side such as petrol
carroll and stuff like that so um this
was my intention all along and it's just
i guess i was just a lucky uh a lucky
receiver of jeffrey's uh you know maybe
poor mood or something i'm not sure what
went wrong for him yesterday but yeah he
seemed like he
he was in a similar manner to me well
let's take a look at the game ilia we're
going to set that up on the screen right
now yeah take us to some of the key
moments you thought
uh he kind of let the position go yeah
honestly i wasn't really familiar with
the way he
he played so i'm i'm more i know uh
white usually plays 95 pretty much right
away after after black plays queen c7
and this
you know um
it forces black to play in in a in a
more of a specific manner not you know i
should i got i got a lot of moves for
free because because he he pushed he
pushed his kingside pawns
um but i'm not sure the position didn't
seem didn't seem worse for white so uh
yeah at this moment yeah we tried to
betray it nice and then we traded
bishops
and here after after cat after a castle
i believe i i spent quite a bit of time
calculating what happens after g4
uh at first i wasn't really sure
what's going on with this movement but
then
i think i settled that i i'll be fine
after i take
f takes g4 queen c4
and yeah so so basically what um the the
thing about this position that white
almost never wants to trade queens
because because if uh if he does and the
position is going to go into an end game
where white has multiple weaknesses such
as the pawn on d5 i have just in general
a better pawn structure in the center et
cetera so he tries to go queen f
i have a pretty much g6 and that's what
i was
going for
and then the point is that quindi sang
queen gets trapped by rook c7 and if
knight a5 yeah
check yeah queen situation so you don't
take on c2 first you go rook c7 yeah
because yeah because if i take first and
then white will probably get more like
rook d2 and now it probably still works
for me but
but i i just
sometimes you just do a queen e4 yeah
it's no way it takes b3
queen b3 or queen c4 maybe even because
queen c4 there is no knight a5 as there
is a checkmate in the first rank yeah
yeah this probably still works for me
but i was honestly a bit too lazy to
calculate once i saw roxy7 works i was
like okay yeah that's enough that's a
very important detail
right um
and if yeah there's no other way for
white to save both their c2 and their
chief or pawn so um obviously the gang
the game can still go on
wyatt can sacrifice upon g4 and and but
i i like my chances it didn't seem like
what will have enough counterplay on the
king's side so that's what i thought um
of g4 and jeffrey very quickly played
jeffrey made his next two moves
instantaneously which which honestly
surprised me quite a bit so he played
the rookie one
um and i played yeah so i played g6 the
g6 actually the attention doesn't really
like my movie six i wonder why um
my alternative
no but then you do the same thing yeah
there's the same queen c4 forces the
queen trade otherwise i still win the
pawn on g4 so i i'm not sure why it
doesn't like g6 i can i give you the
pawn on g4 and try to go for the
checkmate with h5 now that you have the
pawn on g6 if you go h5 we'll just trade
queens i think that's that should be
fine no no like queen d2 just play some
queen d2 get my queen out of the way and
then you take one pawn and then i'll
give you this but you lost the tempo
player rookie one you could have done
the same thing just but now it's
on g6 right
actually yeah the pawn is not has not
become a hook so maybe maybe this this
might be different
rook h1 followed by queen h2 so if i
take on g4 you would play h5 immediately
yes
it's not our pawns we just
well yeah i mean i honestly i did not
believe in white's attack
i was very confident and i mean i don't
know if this is true or not let me ask
the engine the engine says actually the
engine the first time on this show i
agrees with christian oh really okay
thank you thank you thank you so why
does have enough huh is it is it like
winning or plus point three whatever it
is point three okay that's that's as
good as winning in a position like this
if white has advantage it black is done
for uh okay well i guess i might have
underestimated white's counter play then
because i honestly saw that yeah okay so
f4 and for max it's simple right i i
thought yeah i thought that jeffrey
might have expected me to play bishop of
six because
since since i'm trying to play bishop of
six regardless right that's that's a
great place for my bishop to be to be on
yeah yeah draw arrows can sometimes be
hard
but yeah how does this shade come on
the last time you get invited here to
the commentary
i i struggle with that myself that's why
that's a personal attack
yeah it's not there's nothing yeah it's
just i can relate
so i think bishop of six was yes i think
that's probably what jeffrey missed i
don't have to play bishop of six because
now it has a five and that's always
bishop of city
and i think it's important that after
queen c4 you can take on g6 queen d3 and
you can take another opponent yeah so
two pawns yeah this is this tempo and
even these angles are slightly better
when you can pretend that this knight
comes to e4 but of course taking on f7
is quite nice so in the game it felt
that
he was playing for the compensation but
it's a bit speculative i think windy two
is already up it's probably just close
to losing i'm not gonna know why i
honestly saw the queen that he just
can't cannot be played and i saw that he
jeffrey has to play bishop of two here
and going to an end game which once
again i would be very happy with because
i know that i i can never be indentured
i would have taken on these three would
have played rookie eight night f6 yeah
my knight would come come out maybe
would go to g4 apply some pressure
against the d5 phone and yeah i was i
was pretty content with this
um but here yeah i think i think jeffrey
might have missed this idea i i i'm not
sure if this is the most precise
way to solidify my advantage but it
definitely felt like i'm not risking to
lose anymore so as soon as i go for the
for for this for this trade on c2
yeah and i think this was a very
practical i really don't care what the
engine says
we don't have it on anyway okay but
but this looked very clean to me where
just going on and on there on how easy
it is to play this for black and then
the opposite how difficult it is to play
this for white black put something on e5
rolls the pawns right and that's pretty
much what happened yeah exactly but the
thing jeffrey might have might have put
a little bit uh or more of a fight um
later on in the game there was a moment
here if you keep going over here i think
working one that might might have been
or in my mind it might have been the
critical mistake from a practical
standpoint ancient doesn't really agree
actually it doesn't even like my move
rookie too which i wonder why but okay
no matter i thought inside rook f1 why
should should i play rookie 4 which i
thought was the original idea of the
move knight d2 yeah it actually did
think that uh this was the best move
yeah and then i would have obviously
taken on e4 because if i don't come to
e6
but without the rooks it becomes bishop
e5 and then king b3 i think i think this
is this might be the best practical
chance yeah i think i
i saw this but i thought that i'm going
to be faster i didn't even calculate
precisely but jeffrey spent 25 minutes i
believe
before playing rook d to f1 and he might
have just calculated everything until
the end if we try to exchange the
knights now with knight f6 or yes
i thought i thought i can just play kh6
and just start pushing my pawns and i'm
just going to be faster yeah can h6 g5
g4 or g3 you know and this one's like
indeed yeah
yeah so sometimes you calculate yourself
into not allowing yourself chances right
you can calculate it to the end perhaps
you still gave them some chances but the
way that the game continued he was just
way too passive
and the counter play on a6 is just no
good
right i mean the knight doesn't get to
e6 on time and that's why it just yeah
the d5 pawn is a bit too weak to defend
and i i actually like my move rookie too
to force the king uh to the first rank
and to be even more passive so actually
on from on because the king is on d1 and
i'll have uh knight c4 and i have a
whole bunch of uh a bunch of um
um fork strats
especially since the rock went to a3
that became even stronger
well nice uh continuing here for the
tournament you've had a lot of positions
where it seemed like things were going
right you had that position with a
slight edge against london when you had
an extra work against neiman but now
you're converting those those points and
uh you're doing really well yeah right i
i'm obviously i'm extremely happy this
uh this uh this is a really tough event
and i'm i'm glad that after seven months
of break from classical chess i'm i'm
playing this well even so i'm i am
missing
some chances some opportunities but
still you see most of them i'm managing
to convert so i'm i'm gonna try to keep
up to keep up this to keep playing the
same way and then hopefully that's gonna
lead me to
maybe even winning the event
the trend is definitely positive with
you ilya congratulations and we're
looking forward to you in the next round
okay thank you thank you they're always
showing fun chess a incredibly difficult
player to play against and in this
particular event he is showing why he is
such a fearsome opponent certainly
playing with precision and getting the
best out of all of his opponents so far
he's never really been in trouble has
ilya
let's take a look at what we have
remaining we had already those draws
that we had talked about earlier
uh christian what is going on with my
student that's where i want to take you
alejandro and i want to ask your opinion
because i'm not 100 sure if
the position um went his way
because right now okay we see i think we
left it somewhere around
here yeah queen to v8 queen h4 rook fda
rook c6 h6 i think the queen on d5 the
last time we saw it yeah and we were
saying that whenever we're going to see
uh bishop takes d6 which probably has to
come at some point we're going to take
with the e pawn and that seems to be i
wasn't sure i think sometimes you take
with the c rook just to eliminate a
couple of that's what he did and that's
what he did okay that's what he did yes
and then we got to this position but
i feel like black is simplifying a lot
of uh
a lot of material and it doesn't seem
like maybe you will have enough
ammunition to convert this one
d7 queen e7 g3 king f8 queen d4 and now
i'm just simply going to wait
how do you win this position because
whenever you go
queen to d6 to try to transition into a
rook end game i'm going to be able to
take king fa king d7 and grab the pawn
on d7 yeah you never you never trade
those queens you don't do that no
absolutely usually you start playing you
start fortifying your position yeah you
play the move like h5 you put a queen on
d5 you put a rook on d3
and then one day you're going to pretend
so what is the plan let's say rook to d3
let's say i allow you to get your queen
to d5 and then i just sit this is
important that at some point you have to
say with the king because if you say
with the queen on e6 i think that there
will be variations where i just take it
right and perhaps i cannot take it here
i don't know but there will be
variations where i put my king on g2
first absolutely and those absolutely
those end games might be and then you
will get your kingdom
my king is 35 and somehow i win yeah so
let's pretend that you have to keep on
shuffling i just go
yeah
how do you continue
sometimes you play a tricky move like
rook e3 here i don't think it works
because you can take with the queen
actually maybe even taking with the rook
also works so i cannot really do that uh
i can go up with the king i don't know
what it does that's okay
and
now the question is what do i do right
that's the thing i just simply don't see
another way to improve your position
except potentially starting to push your
pawns in front of the king but that
opens up the discussion of how safe your
uh king is going to be that's pretty
simple it's pretty safe i mean
there will be some possibilities of
perpetual but i mean the work on d8 is
just permanently stuck right at the
moment the moment you move at a queen
with a check so i don't even have to
really calculate any of that
you can put your queen
let's say i don't know
h2
you can even put your queen to see it if
i felt like it right i'm still gonna
wait
like where's where's the breakthrough
how do you force me out
of my shell
it's hard to say right
it almost feels like it's borderline
losing but it
very close very close but it's it's
it's missing the last mechanism it feels
like it's one attacking move away and
it's possible that darsh will have to
organize some kind of
pawn storm as you mentioned to try to
create those threats
and that begs the question
was it better to just simply take with
this pawn no i think in this in this
game scenario i can take on on b2 queen
a4 and this one might be an even harder
version because you do get the two rooks
but i can't actually push my king right
if i put my queen on f6 and i just stay
yeah this one might be even harder
because you can't
push anything and seems like the engine
is agreeing with you in that assessment
alejandro uh okay so let's see where we
are right now this is the position we
currently have on the board
queen to c6 was the last move so i'm
expecting something along the lines of
king g8 right i feel your king g8 i
start bringing my king at some point i
start bringing my pawns this will be a
slow steady torture it's it's going to
be unclear
which pawns i push yeah but i'm running
out of ideas so at some point you just
do it g4 gt5
it's your only idea if it works it
doesn't matter
you have to do it and hopefully you open
up enough avenues for a trick
down the line yep and he will try for a
very long time let's see what's
happening
in uh chris repca's game because i feel
this one kind of slipped as well
we thought that chris has a very uh
potent attack right i think it was
something along the lines of
this position yeah this one's very
promising but his king was like the
black king cannot really castle very
easily so we saw this move bishop to e7
queen to d4
f6 why not castle you might ask well
actually
i'm going to go queen to b6 which is
going to force the queen trade and after
the queen trade of course you cannot
stop my uh b pawn from promoting
grabbing the exchange also this rook
coming to d7 this is just simply all she
wrote for black so instead of that he
played this move f6 this is a move that
you don't want to play in this type of
position with the king still stuck in
the center queen to c4
g5 this is another movie you don't want
to play with the king stuck in the
center but he was going for it and it
seems like this move bishop to d6 was
not the correct approach it is a bit of
a mystifying move to me to move bishop
d6 i understand why he wants to get the
d6 score so badly
but you want to keep material to attack
your opponent and it feels like this is
a bit too much on the simplifying scale
yes and uh indeed that seems to be the
case because right now after queen 36 i
would assume he thought he saw that he's
invading he saw that he's going to take
on e6 and he felt like the king is just
simply too vulnerable right now and
probably going to be checkmated
it's not the case it doesn't seem to be
the case and uh it feels like black is
backing this game and potentially
getting very very well first of all what
if i just simply take yeah he's going to
get a pawn up end game but hey at this
level you never win well i wouldn't say
that at all the structure is a bit
strange right you're a bit too advanced
you get you get h5 g4 and this is
complete draw
yeah
you know at the 2700 level i guarantee
that this is a draw 99 of the time at
this level i have seen people lose it
once in a while
so it's not like i'm gonna say it's a
dead draw especially because you don't
have the usual structure and it seems
like they haven't
traded the queens really yeah actually
i'm a little shocked at that you have
the chance of trading the quiz and going
into that technical end game i think you
have to take it i think that's just
i think that's just optimism
yeah i mean your king's on g6 dude
you you can trade queens the moment it's
offered to you you take it and then you
think later and he has two minutes on
the clock two minutes and 30 seconds on
the clock with the king on g6 completely
exposed
you're going to leave the queens on the
board this is not a very good practical
decision by mikhail
it's not even about whether the move is
strong or not strong it's just such a
strange practical decision not a good
practical decision
a lot of a lot of the times you can see
that players have very similar
understanding they have some very
similar amount of tactics very similar
uh capacity in the openings but
sometimes
some players are just savvier
when it comes to making this kind of of
difficult decisions in time pressure and
and applying logic because right
sometimes when you get to these
positions you're in time pressure you're
calculating calculating calculating in
one of them you calculate your up down
upon and the other one you calculate
you're not down upon but it's kind of
obvious from an outsider's perspective
somebody that's not calculating
variation somebody that's looking at the
position without really counting move by
move that where you start in this
position is that you start by turning
off the queens and it doesn't matter if
you lose a pawn
because
when you see that this queen on e2 can
just only 16 just retreat to e2 you're
kind of left wondering why didn't i snap
it
when i could right and you know from a
technical perspective that that end game
is a draw yeah you know you have to know
that you know it you it's kind of
uncomfortable sometimes that you don't
really want to defend it
you want to lift but sometimes you just
have to sometimes you have to bite the
bullet in chess and and use those
doveretsky endgame manual techniques
and say i know how to do it i read the
book even if it was like 25 years ago i
still know how to do it
and you have to prove it and it's part
of being a grandmaster
i really don't like this decision to
play rook d6 but all right we'll move on
from here for a little bit uh
to finish off the a group uh it seems
like
the game between misha and tipoff and
ray robson should pretty much finish at
any moment uh
and they've got back his spawn he's
still in the slightly worse of a
completely drawn position
work through a5 rook to d1 yeah that
pawn this pawn is dead but there's not
that just defensive dude you can just
defend they broke d1
nothing's going to happen i mean if it
was difficult to win darius's position
imagine
how difficult it is to win this position
you're never going to do that all right
so this one i expect will go to a draw
uh the irish roussette was pressing
uh i'm curious on the camille dragon
game against hans niemann
well he's a pawn up he is a pawn up and
it's not just that right it's the
possibility of the connected past pawns
on
the other side of the board that has me
kind of concerned not kind of because
i'm very concerned uh for hans in this
position
i think objectively this should be
winning yeah i think absolutely yeah the
knight on a very bad scenario can even
come to d5 or e4
uh the part on f4 is just not going
anywhere actually rook d3 oh this is a
threat i understand knight x4 is a
threat and i'm picking up the pawn but
i'm assuming rook f6 is coming
and then i think even a move like rook
d3
block it with the king on f3 put the
king on f3 it's on a light square put
everything on a light square this is
good technique your opponent has a dark
square bishop you don't blunder anything
very simply by putting everything on a
light square so this guy goes on the
light square this guy goes on a light
square uh the knight will eventually
have to go to a dark square at some
point but not for a while he plays and
rook d3 and camille is of my generation
a little bit less but not that much less
he understands perfectly how to play
these positions
and he might be getting his first
victory i think i think this one said
this looks very hopeless for black the
rook comes to d5 at some point i can
start pushing the pulse on the queen
side but quite honestly
i could probably spend a few tempe
spend a few effort tempe into just
picking up f4
just pick up the pawn it's a bit
uncomfortable you do have to play rook
f3 rook d4 rookie four take the pawn so
let's see what if i just put my bishop
on e3 right so let's say bishop c5 but
that's the thing right if you go bishop
c5 here and bishop b3
then again this rook might take a while
to get there but i'll put it here or
i'll put it somewhere
where i'm attacking um f4 i could even
start with the move like rook c3 and c5
b4
yeah and and you're gonna you just don't
have enough pieces right
you don't have enough pieces to do
everything you need to do you need to
defend against the c pawn against the uh
defend against the attacks on the f pawn
your king's pretty far away
and even if it wasn't far away it's hard
to improve him
this looks very very close to hopeless
well
one game that is definitely hopeless uh
is and we're going to stay within the a
group is the one between lenderman and
sam savion because sam is just breaking
through at this point let's see what
happened uh we left it off after queen
to g4 this was the last move and we saw
a very confident sam in uh the the
position on camera we saw that he
understands and it's actually it's our
scripture yeah actually over alex
lenderman resigns against sam seven
who's having a heck of a year wow
chest-wise just uh improving
constraining
uh dramatically i would say after being
stuck for a very long time in the low to
mid 2600s i'm going to call it right now
he's playing like a 27 plus player right
now well yeah
we we could check the tpr for that
confirm it but not only in this
tournament but in the past year yeah in
the past years it feels you at some
point you feel when a player makes that
leap forward yeah he's he's had a stream
and he's had a string of good events
right it's not just this event it's not
just a grand prix that he had a
fantastic showing in but also the us
championship where he tied for first
place with wesley saw and fabiano
carrano of course we can't really say he
died for first place because he lost the
playoff but in the normal tournament he
got as many points as those two players
and when you're in the company of wesley
saw and fabiano caron and your chess
results something is going well in your
career so just take us through how this
finished up christian yes absolutely so
after queen to g4 of course you see this
pressure on e4 and this is exactly what
you need to find as black in the
position where are the targets where is
my next target it looks like you're
giving up a rook but no you're not
actually giving up a rook because once
you take it i take your rook with
devastating consequences another the
pawns are still equal nevertheless i'm
invading and
you're simply suffocating at this point
with the white pieces you don't have any
squares for your pieces queen to f1 has
to drop back because otherwise you get
checkmated i'm not going to exchange the
queens and you cannot take this pawn on
h3 this is a key um idea in the position
because if you take on h3 of course we
see the bishop on c1 just simply hanging
there so
what he played was rook to a2 rook takes
f2 rook takes f2 h5 i'm not even
concerned about taking your pawn on e4
sure you can take this pawn on e4 but i
want to preserve this pawn on h3 this is
a very annoying pawn for white's
position just whole seam uh suffocated
there
and after uh rook takes f2 he played the
move h5
trying to create another weakness in the
position h4 as we were mentioning
previously trying to break through on
the king's side and checkmate the white
king queen to e2 do you want to trade
the queens absolutely not queen to g6
queen to f3 h4
very very nice play
by white c he takes d4 c takes d4 hey
guess what i have another pawn on the e
file that i can attack your center and
open up my bishop finally including my
last piece into the attack
once this guy opens up well this is
going to be all she wrote for the player
with the white pieces alex leonard that
is we have this position queen takes g3
and at this point he was like okay i'm
completely disgusted with my position
we're going to enter an end game
where i'm going to lose every single
pawn in the position
bishop coming to d4
this pawn on a4 is a huge weakness
you have absolutely no chance to create
any sort of counter play no more pawns
on this side for white to even hope and
dream that you could potentially
get something close to promotion this is
just simply over alex understands that
he resigns the game and i believe sam
savion might be getting his first
victory of uh these this event he was on
uh 50 percent now he's on plus one that
actually surprises me he's had such a
solid event but yeah and it might not be
the case i might be wrong in that regard
but i think you might be able to try it
he actually surprised nishnik on the
first round how got a really good
position from the opening but nishnik
was able to draw that one i don't think
if sam has won a game here
it feels like he has because he was in
the good side of a position he has not
but
he has not fifi
moving to plus one very nice for him all
right let's go to the uh some games that
we've neglected a little bit but i think
they're uh wrapping up
somehow this king was getting checkmated
in the center but it is no longer
getting checkmated in the center that's
a good news for hungaski the bad news
for mungowski it's getting checkmated in
the queen side
and i think uh i think so just work
somewhere just works yes
and i think the fact that he's also down
the pawn is really not
uh that relevant
this seems completely lost right i don't
even have to turn on an engine yeah and
we we have this opposite color uh bishop
situation with major uh pieces on the
board and we know that uh the biggest
factor of assessment in this type of
positions is who has the initiative and
who has the safer king and the answer to
that question is obvious in this case
white has the initiative and the black
king is completely naked so
just by that you're going to understand
that white is completely winning yeah
and then you start calculating stuff and
you see that well there's probably no
way to defend the immediate threats
do you want to trade queens absolutely
not not going to go queen city
it's only like an academic uh thought
but if you trade queens i still think
white is completely wrong
yes yes that h pawn is extremely
important yeah yeah
it's actually going down the board i do
have one extra pawn as white but it's
technically two in many end games
because these two double a pawns are
going nowhere but that as we said is is
a dumb academic thought uh the fact is
the king on eight is just
uh completely exposed i expect to move
like queen c1 or queen c2 i'm not really
sure which was the most accurate and
that should be the end of the game
uh a great run here for avi manu mishra
is is that making it a hat trick three
in a row yeah very nice there for uh the
youngster bouncing back from a loss
against jj alimorandi in the second
round and then winning three in a row uh
to catapult himself not quite to first
place because chris refers kill still is
slaying the tournament
but
certainly happy with his performance
well he's going to be on three and a
half that's a plus two uh going into the
second part of the event
definitely a comforting result at this
point of course you're not there yet to
winning the event
um but you're close you're absolutely
close speaking of players that can win
the event curious on the christopher you
game and why he has not finished
because i had chris is trying chris i
think so i think i think it's awesome
that's trying really
no that's just white
oh is he yes he is yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah then el shawn
yes
but uh i'm i'm actually a little curious
what are you playing against uh rook ge3
you just moved the king to hp to h4 yeah
i would assume that's the only and like
nothing happened right
no well you can go back right or you can
go to e1
so what happens if you try to go to e1 i
think you just have to go look at fade
there's a slight trick in this position
christian wants to trick me as he
usually does
it's not a great trick because you lose
b6 at the end but there's this trick
where you go check let me just put some
kind of inane move
to show it check here rook takes g3
takes king rook g1 and there's the
secure at the end but unfortunately well
i actually did not see that but thank
you for giving me credit for it i'll
take the credit for it it's good stuff
christian just take it um
but i think most sensible moves here
with black are with white no the problem
is that after rookie one i think rook of
faith might be problematic for black
yeah but i'll play rookie seven i mean
i've taken rook h8
oh do you want to get into this kind of
now you lose a pawn and who knows what's
next yeah i think he might be losing
this it's an interesting end game
actually not sure of the evaluation of
it
but it's definitely certainly not not
something christopher wants to see so
perhaps going with the rook of the one
to e1 is very very very unnecessary just
keep it where it is
but what if i isn't luca wait wait wait
so isn't rook fade actually a threat
right rookie fade is certainly a threat
right now yeah okay i agree with defense
how do you defend against that
all right
let us start with the
i actually like this move okay but the
thing is what do i do here and i think
he played it i'm
my side is not that great but i think i
see something on e3 uh yes there's
something on d3 actually d3 there you go
my site is not great at all
ah so that makes a lot of sense of
course
wait no
no it does it doesn't make any sense how
does something go to d3 maybe we can get
the uh
we can we have the boards here now uh he
played rookie three king h4
god instead of rookie one he did play
the move rook ed3
which uh it just kind of passes the move
it says yes rook f8 you can play you can
pick up the pawn h on f7 but i'll pick
up the pawn on g3 and i assume he's
calculated this out to a draw the
youngster fight at this point of life
calculates better than i do so
i will believe him
yeah i guess it's true right rook f8 is
the only winning try
rook takes g3
you take this way you're never going to
go anywhere so you take the other way
king here but
if i keep giving checks i feel i'm just
improving your king
but i don't have another plan so what if
i take with the other rook
the other rook i just felt i just move
to e6 and then i go to f6
and then i just keep
[Music]
running
but now i take a pawn right
i don't see where you take the pawn you
have this 36 here but i can always take
it back no no no i'll take on h6
ah you take that pawn
that part yeah and that part might be
more valuable
actually that's not so easy yeah
i still feel this is within the realm of
a draw but you start wondering why i
shed a pawn for this
yeah these four rook end games are
always extremely tricky yeah they're
somewhat tricky at this point right yeah
i mean i could go rook g1 and pretend
that you're right
g6
and then maybe i'll get my king to h6 if
i manage to do that
i'm getting very close to pushing that
pawn down the board yeah i don't see a
very clean solution here actually let's
go back a couple of moves yeah maybe
after rook f6 tried to keep connection
with the rooks and then seven
it's not a move i really want to make
though but sometimes in chess
you just have to make the ugly move but
king e7 yes you can force me even down
to the eighth rank
because right now i have a threat right
this is h3 followed by the other rook to
g3 and then taking on h5 with the check
yeah i want to see that pawn uh from h5
out yeah i want it off the board
that's the biggest threat
in the position for me
yeah
yeah it might be ugly but it might be
sufficient as they say and
i don't have the tempe to create
something and defend my pawn on h5 at
the same time
no not a shocker right that this should
end in a draw
no
all right uh speaking of games the mind
and the draw do i have any updates in my
students game i'm actually really
curious about that end game no and we
probably will not have any updates until
about 9 or 9 30 p.m today
because i mean
the only way you make progress here you
push the king you make mu 49 with a pawn
you're just the king well there is some
uh changes that are happening in the
position and that is uh we remember the
queen was in front
right now the queen is behind uh this
battery on the d file for white so we
see the recon i like this idea because
it does protect
the king much better when i'm going to
start pushing my pawns and this is
exactly i mean this is the only way i
can make any progress so right now i'm
seeing in the future of this game
something along the lines of k2 h3
followed by g4 g5 this is the big
question right now how are you going to
attack this hook on h6 this is the pawn
that you have to focus your attention on
are you going to go straight up with a
g4 g5 or are you first going to block
that pawn with h5 this is the question
uh that daryus is going to have to
answer there you go
h5 there you go he answered it he
answered it h5 blocking this let's say
uh hook weakness however you want to
look at it on h6 and that's why he put
this rook on d6 right because whenever
we're going to get to the point where my
pawn lands on a g5 well with the rook on
d6 the pressure on h6 is going to be
reinforced i like this idea and there's
a small trick right that if you're a
king f8
take on h6 very nice very nice alejandro
you've been doing your tactics uh yes
because if you take queen h8 that's game
over obviously and you don't have time
well actually you can yeah but the
problem the problem is that you probably
get made it but i assume that even the
pawn end game after rook takes these
takes d8 of course yeah even this is
lost yeah you can take on g7 you can
take on d8 and yeah
that's not a good move
that's a mouse slip of course
um i like what he's doing and i think he
definitely found uh some sort of an idea
at least right yeah
it's it's blocking um well it's only
giving a couple of options for black
only king king f8 no longer possible
king h8 no no longer possible king h7
king g8 seem to be kind of the only two
moves that black has in the position and
i will be uh pushing my pawns in the
near future i like what he's doing he's
definitely developing this position uh
we're going to have to wait and see
whether he's going to be able to convert
but he has great chances so we'll be
waiting for a while uh so we do expect a
win soon by abhimanyu
uh let me check check out chris rapka's
game after this time pressure
it feels like a lot happened
black did improve his position
significantly just because of this queen
being on d5 but
still
it feels like it's all white to play
that that being said
did he just really play g4 that was this
last move yes yes it was so what happens
if i take i simply take back and then i
go rotate shade
because now for the first time in
forever
black has a real
actual threat well
yeah that's actually the way he should
be going according to the engine at
least
this feels like well if i play queen e4
then we just you have to play queen e4
uh if i have to play queen e4 then this
is just a dead draw we i don't you don't
even get to pick up a pawn the way that
you did in the other roken games right
no no not at all no no no this is not
good for his winning chances
no this one i think is really speeding
up to a draw i can't imagine not taking
on g4 in this position with black and he
has all the time to calculate because
the players just made time control this
is move 41 yeah isn't 41 for chris we'll
let him actually this is mu41 why did he
play it so fast
he thought he played he took a minute
and 30 seconds to play the very
committal move g4 that's
not a good practical decision no no
there will certainly be
tough topics discovered
today at the dinner table at the mizzou
dinner table
uh and is that it do we have anything
else left because dragon seems like
dragon is definitely heading towards the
victory that's this is just over he's
making great progress i i don't think
hans even uh
believes that he can save you yeah i
don't think he tries too hard
i think
i think
it has come to the point
where i think you actually take the
bishop yeah right now you take the
bishop i think you take the bishop and
then you start harassing the other pawns
well you take the bishop you make sure
that you're not going to lose one of
your pawns so you probably go a4 first i
think i actually start here i think it's
a bit clever or you can do that because
this is a lost pawn ending game i assume
i'm not going to count it out but i
assume this opponent game that's lost
um
which means that you're and you have to
enter it right otherwise you take one a7
yeah uh
and if you have to defend this way then
i'll collect this one immediately that's
an important detail it's an important
detail for the pawn you don't have time
for the activity so i think knight c7
rook h5
i maybe maybe you can pretend with after
h6 that you still are in the game but i
feel
i feel you're not no no no no it feels
like uh
he's definitely heading towards his
first victory yeah good for camille to
uh come back in the tournament of course
uh not good for hans demon fans and he
has a lot of them he's one of the rising
juniors here in uh america just making
an incredible leap
in uh in raiding
um
and i think that's it right i don't
think we're missing anything from the
rest of the games
no no no so we looked at darius's game
we looked at uh what's on tip off doing
and deep according to this that must be
a draw wait what
i mean what is it i mean i still think
it's a draw but
it's one of those draws that once you
put it on the board and you realize what
you had five moves ago you're thinking
how did i do this to myself right how do
you go from
how do you go from this position it
looks pretty
especially specifically this position i
thought right
yeah you can see it's a bit unpleasant
but i mean one thing you don't want to
do is actually exchange the rooks but i
guess rook a3 forces that
okay the rk3 actually forces that this
is all forced
yeah you have to take right sorry the
queens you're the only one the queens
yeah because queen c2 does the important
detail it allows rook to g3
let me point that out queen c2 i don't
want to take too much time we'll get
back to it this is of course a losing
move because
is it
yeah and then i
have
queen c3 and with us we have tactician
and winning his game today sam savion
he's had a good tournament but he
finally feels like he broke through
sam how do you feel today
definitely feels good to finally win a
game
i've had a few chances tournament but i
really didn't convert
well let's look at your game sam because
that was simply a masterpiece uh when
did you feel you're taking over
uh it was actually near the end of the
game when i played queen h5
i have a very powerful partner not
before
no not before we can go through the game
yeah let's let's let's go through the
game um
where do you want to start because uh
this is knight g4 queen f6 idea yeah
sure we can go down there yeah it felt
like you came in
looking for blood right yeah
ga g5 you threw the kitchen sink at him
and i was really happy about this knight
d8 move because
yeah tonight's just going to f4 and
either you have to give away your
italian bishop or
allow it to land on f4 right and it
feels that
i i did feel it was a bit impractical to
um
to allow it to allow knight but the
engine was suggesting that after night
for knight d5 was a very strong move in
this position i'm actually interested in
that line so knight d5 knight takes e2
you take back a queen d8 and they just
wanted to kick out uh this guy on g4
with h3
i think the move knight h6 fails
tactically right yeah probably just the
bishop g5 i was i think i wanted to play
c6 c6 is probably forced and i think the
surprising part was how it evaluated
this as so much better for
for what that's definitely surprising so
bishop takes g4
c4 vision g4 and it is a computer so you
can imagine oh it just takes the box it
just collects it thinks pawns are free
thank you very much
and it did give white a sizable
advantage but of course a very scary
line seeing it from afar also down the
exchange
uh but after rook d2 it it almost felt
like it was his final mistake did he
play rook d too fast uh relatively yeah
relatively quickly
yeah perhaps they didn't feel the danger
of this position i'm definitely happy
about knight takes e3 and g4
uh he found an interest was a huge
detail we have very important detail
with knight h3
oh yes not issue is important because if
let's say queen g5 efe f2 yeah what's
fine
and you no longer have that pawn on e5
to
attack the center bishop a7 is going to
stay locked forever
right
so we got to this position and it felt
you got everything you wanted
i think his the the reason i said queen
schwab is because when i played rook the
f8 here
one of the key uh ideas in this position
is that if you take on f8 and play rook
f2 yeah uh i can take on f2 and he
cannot recapture with the queen because
of adcd bishop takes d4 so
that pin actually works for me
um
and what he did is he can you go queen
f7 after taking on d4
yeah f7 here it's on a little bit of
counter play oh yes that's a good move
king d8 though can you then now take on
d4 you can do it before or after it
doesn't really matter
you can you can still take yeah king d8
is a big move
kinky seven i still seem safe yet yeah
you're still good yeah you can even go
to c6 probably yes the engine defends it
but we don't care what the engine thinks
so so i think his big mistake is b5
because he allowed me to play a5 and
then bishop b6 the king goes to a7 under
post right uh if he played a5 instead of
b5 i would have to play c6
and my king is still weak right in that
position yeah but now he's extremely
happy right just has no moves maybe this
is the time that he should have gone for
takes takes in rook after oh yeah for
sure for sure yeah without the ability
of going to c6 in many variations but he
missed that chance and it felt
once this king got to a7 i love it by
the way very kasparov like right you
improve your king to the maximum before
you get that killing blow and
this it was a very bad symptom this
bishop c1 bishop d2
and once you put the queen on h5 we saw
how you put this queen on g4 you
certainly must have fouled you were
winning yeah here i felt like it's close
to winning
yeah it's 5h4 incoming
with great effect sam tell us a little
bit about uh your year in chess not so
much in the calendar their year but
you've had not so busy but very
successful year uh in the past few
tournaments you've attained all-time
highs in your rating uh what what's
clicked
uh well i played no tournaments during
the pandemic as many people
also weren't able to play
and i basically just worked on chess
those two years
i've only played four or five events i'd
say
the pandemic but but they went well they
went very well
well that uh work is definitely paying
off sam congratulations once again and
good luck in the rest of your games
thank you absolutely sam savion one of
the strongest players here in america
playing in the us chess championship
doing a fantastic job there playing in
the grand prix and now playing here at
this lewis chess club yet again in the
spring classic with his first victory
honestly we were surprised it was his
first victory because he's always
showing solid preparation solid ideas
and
calculates really really well so
sam moves to plus one
quite the severally so lenderman having
a little bit of a tough time
um finding his stride he he
he's had a rough few months and i think
it's showing i think london was going to
have to sit back at the drawing board
and figure out what's going on for him
to improve on his chess
so we have five games remaining five
games done i believe that is correct
uh let's see where do we want to go and
a few of them are just about to uh end
and gasket definitely
is close to resigning yeah this this
king is not
not surviving
hence neiman close to resigning
yeah so we see this king is just uh
being yeah
this king is not going to survive uh
meanwhile hans niemann did
camille did old school style go into the
end game so just play a4 i think a4 is
sufficient i think every move wins
but i i i would i would find it
difficult to find a grand match without
some play the move a4 in this position
just so that you can have the move a5
later on in the game in case that you
need to defend the a pawn but as
mentioned i mean
most moves that don't blunder the rook
in one move
are winning
except king e4 actually that's also not
winning
well that almost blunders the rook in
one move almost yes
because you will have to give them
it up
meanwhile
this is becoming
not what on people wanted i have to
admit this is becoming more unpleasant
every time i look at it it is a
three versus two but with the pawn on e6
this is pretty much a draw it's very
difficult to make progress with the
black pieces but with the pawn on d6 on
the other hand but the pawn on d6 and
the king on g2 already cut
there's some serious winning chances for
black i'm not really sure how you make
immediate progress i don't know at first
you put the rick on d7 or even on b6 to
maybe support the rook at the pawn from
the back
it does uncut the king so it's not an
easy decision to make
but whatever happened it's clear that
black has some very realistic winning
chances whereas a few moves ago
i would have thought that the players
would just
shake
their hands agreed to a draw and go home
but
even the minor slip at this level of
chess
will cause a great deal of suffering for
your position and this is what happens
uh with antipovo maybe with the move g3
earlier on
where i felt
yeah this is a draw but
you have to be a little bit more careful
not to get into these kind of positions
and then we have a bunch of games that
seem
like they will go for a while well just
to show what antipov uh should have done
in this endgame not to have to worry
about
uh all this defense that right now he's
facing at this point this was very close
to the time um the second time control
moved 39.
he played this move king to g2 a very
easy move to make right you're just
getting closer uh to the center you're
activating your king but
that just loses a very crucial tempo
what he had to do at this point and he
only had 52 seconds he had to calculate
the most critical continuation and that
is rook to g4 attacking the pawn you
want to exchange as many points as
possible
now after king to g6 f4 f6
my assumption is that this is where he
stopped he saw that he takes stakes you
cannot move the rook without losing the
pawn and this is going to be quite
unpleasant after king coming to f5 king
going to e5 potentially losing this pawn
right
but right now he just has to simply
continue one extra move forward go rook
to e4 you're obviously threatening rook
to e6 and that's going to capture the
pawn on d6 you're giving up the g3 pawn
but after king to f2 there's no way well
you can go king to f5 but after rook to
e6 you're not going to take on g3
allowing that losing
king and pawn end game but you're
actually going to go rook to e6 capture
the pawn on d6 and there's absolutely no
way in which black can uh win this
position this would have been a very
very easy draw and very forced as well
this is what you have to be looking for
forced ways in which you can simplify
the position he did not find this he
chose to make the easy move get closer
the time uh time control king to g2 but
right now he's he's going to be
suffering this position absolutely after
g4 as you were mentioning the computer
already really really likes black very
very close uh to a decisive advantage
rook to b6 just played slow right
because this pawn is going to land on f6
right and the rook on b6 is going to
protect it later on when the pawn from
d6 is going to move down the board this
is a very nice setup for black to try to
activate his pc's king to c5 followed by
uh d5 you will not have to worry about
your pawn structure and white well white
is going to have to fight very very hard
uh for for the draw in this position
let's not let the audience think that we
think this is winning for black we do
think this should be in the realm of a
draw technical yes this should be in the
realm of a technical draw the thing is
you slip once
and mistakes rarely come alone you feel
psychologically that you should never
have gotten into this to begin with
and it affects your mood and sometimes
it's difficult to sit down and actually
force the draw right it's not like it
was his choice to get into this position
well it's also a repeating pattern for
uh mihail specifically in this event
because he lost with the white pieces
also in the djoko piano also a position
that was very very close to a draw
against uh darius yerge a couple of
rounds ago and uh at some point he had
this option of simplifying and going
into an equal land game which he did not
take
he tried uh he tried to go for a more
and unfortunately that wasn't enough he
just simply missed an easy tactic and
lost very easily in that game and
when those patterns start repeating you
start losing confidence
and is extremely important with the
clock ticking as we will see well this
is going to become a very difficult
defense yeah plenty of time for both
players they have um obviously breached
the move uh 40. i mean
it's kind of clear considering how much
material there is on the board
but
it's still it's not going to be easy for
for misha here he's getting a warm
welcome to america a tough
tough event here
and
mori adiabati is still trying against
christopher you
starting to really lose hope in white's
chances here
you will have to play rook f8 ideas at
some point but
they just never really quite seem to be
enough
you can always move the rook to b7 the
moment you trade works you might as well
sign the score sheets because that's a
draw even without the b-pawn
but if you go something like rook here
and i keep passing
at some point you're going to have to
play the move rook cafe and just buy the
bullet and go for that end game because
if you don't do that
well there's really no plan
that's pretty much all there is to it so
besides that we have uh okay neiman is
about to resign congratulations about to
resign and chris replica did play the
move queen e4 which we thought was
absolutely mandatory i'm still baffled
by his decision to play g4 in a minute
and a half yeah take stakes no at move
41. yeah move 41. yeah that's the thing
41. you kind of get it like
they they tell us this kind of young and
early but we never listen that don't
make committing pawn moves or move 40.
you totally get that right you don't do
that but you already did
get reached
you already reached time control so you
if you wanted to make a committed move
here you can do it but spend the time on
it the move g4 and you see that is a
question that i want to ask you how you
approach this because sometimes
you don't trust let's say your
scoresheet
you see that you've written that this is
move40 but you don't actually trust it
and you want to make that one extra move
just to make sure right yeah i get that
because on the clock i don't think he
sees that he's getting the extra 30
minutes i think everybody gets this
panic right yeah that
that did i really make 40 did i really
not double write one but i mean you just
have to trust yourself sometimes in this
kind of scenarios especially you know
you can peek at your opponent then
exactly
if it matches then you're good if it
doesn't match then you panic also
exactly with this move when you have in
mind ideas of playing moves such as g4
yeah you have to relax for a second
and just wait and think about it and
don't play the move g4 look the position
is getting closer to equality right yeah
it's pretty obvious yeah queen on d5
very nicely placed you have some
pressure on a b4
but
do you really want to play g4 and give
your opponent this type of counter
chances on the h file
um
never
no i i it really baffles me what the
move g4 was about but
it's one of those slight practical
decisions that you you sometimes look
back on and you really don't understand
it yeah and again it's not one of those
situations in which we think this
completely changes the character of the
position it goes from winning to to draw
not anything like that black has made
incredible amount of headway in
defending his position the queen 95 is a
monstrous piece
but that being said pretty much any move
that was not g4 you have to give the
edge to why there's still a more
comfortable king it's still a better
structure keep the pressure off keep the
pressure and when we're talking about
literally any movement i mean literally
move right rookie six rookie four rookie
three whatever h2 yeah
all right well we are needing nearing
the end of our broadcast here in uh the
singles chess club as we are giving you
as much as we can in a reduced schedule
but let's take a look at what's happened
so far in the a group today as we do
have a lot of results well uh it seems
like this is a round in which black is
definitely doing amazing he already won
two games ilya nishni and sam sevion one
with the black pieces it seems like
camille is going to score his first
victory uh that's going to uh be a
victory for him against hans niemann
darius is still trying against aram
jacobian and ray robson once again with
the black pieces is putting some
pressure on the struggling mikhail
antipov and how about the big group
yeah the big group it doesn't shake up
that much but i think the biggest result
of the day by far is going to be
abhimanyu mishra defeating robert
hungaski we actually expect all the
other games to end in a draw yeah and
and that means that mishra is putting a
little bit more pressure on chris repka
no absolutely after a potential win by
mishra a potential draw by chris repkin
uh christopher yu
i think uh mishra is going to be on
three and a half uh joining christopher
are you in second position and there are
going to be one full point behind chris
ref yeah an absolutely great showing
there by the two youngsters of the
tournament and christopher you and abby
vanya mishra but also the collegiate guy
saying hey i still can make progress and
a replica showing scintillating chess
perhaps not his best day today but still
four and a half out of five is just an
incredible score to start absolutely
well we had a lot of fun alejandro today
another great round and we're going to
be back
tomorrow at the same time same time 3 am
pm central time the games start don't
forget two and a half hours earlier at
1pm central time and we're going to see
you during the show yeah see you
tomorrow
[Music]
any reproduction or distribution of this
content without the express written
consent of the st louis chess club is
prohibited